Luis ha comido con su familia
en un restaurante.
El total de la cuenta por la familia
fue 52 dólares
y Luis
quedó contento con el servicio
por lo que va a dejar
25% de propina.
Él desea saber la cantidad total...
la cantidad total que
debe dejar en la mesa.
Elige la ecuación
que puede usar Luis
y determina el total
de la cuenta incluyendo propina.
Así que lo que no sabemos,
lo que debemos calcular es la cantidad total que debe dejar en la mesa.
Llamemos a esto "x".
Hay varias maneras
de hacer esto,
consideremos primero la razón
entre la cantidad total que él va a pagar
y el total de la cuenta.
La razón de lo que él va a pagar
y lo que en realidad fue la cuenta.
Y eso debe de ser
exactamente igual a la razón
entre los
correspondientes porcentajes.
Así es que si consideramos
el total de la cuenta
como el 100%,
la cuenta es el 100%,
pero él no quiere pagar
tan solo el 100%,
él quiere pagar
el 100% de la cuenta,
más 25% de propina...
más 25% de propina.
Y éste de aquí
lo podemos reescribir como,
"x" sobre
es igual a 100% más 25%
es 125%
y eso sobre 100%.
Si vemos las opciones
que nos dan,
esta última es nuestra respuesta
intercambiando los lados,
125% es a 100%
como "x" es a 52.
Entonces podemos elegir ésta
y esto hace sentido,
la razón de lo que él va a pagar
incluyendo la propina,
con respecto al 100%
ó el porcentaje que el va a pagar
incluyendo la propina,
125% con respecto al 100%
es igual a la cantidad total que él paga
con respecto al total de la cuenta.
Veamos si alguna de estas
otras opciones es válida.
En ésta se establece que la razón
del total de la cuenta con respecto al 100%
es igual a la razón total que él va a pagar
con respecto al 125%,
ésta de aquí hace sentido.
Voy a reescribirla por acá
para que la veamos claramente.
Nos están diciendo que la razón
de los 52 dólares
del total de la cuenta
con respecto al 100%
y queremos encontrar...
déjame mejor poner esto en azul...
así es que
corresponde al 100%
y queremos ver
si esta razón es la misma
que la razón del total
de lo que está pagando,
con respecto al 125%.
Así es que al incrementar
ésta en 25%,
también hay que incrementar esta cantidad
en 25%
para obtener la cantidad total
que realmente se tiene que pagar.
Así es que esta respuesta
también es correcta.
¿Qué pasa con esta?
¿La razón de 100% a 125%
es igual a la razón de "x" a 52?
No,
ésta de aquí no hace sentido,
pues ésta es la razón del total
de la cuenta con respecto
al total de la cuenta
más la propina
y aquí tenemos la cuenta
con propina y sin propina,
si invertimos esto
como 52 entre "x"
sí se cumple la igualdad,
pero así como está las razones
no corresponden.
Así es que ésta
no la marcamos.
Lo último que debemos
hacer es calcular,
cuánto debe dejar Luis,
incluyendo la propina.
Para eso
vamos a despejar "x"
de esta ecuación.
Empezamos entonces
multiplicando ambos lados por 52,
del lado derecho
los 52 se cancelan,
así es que nos queda "x"
es igual a 125% sobre 100% que es
1.25
y esto que multiplica
a 52.
¿Y esto cuánto es?
1.25 por 52...
veamos..
13 por 4 = 52
por 1.25 por 4...
no, no quiero hacer un error...
lo voy a hacer mejor de este lado,
voy a hacer de este lado
la multiplicación.
1.25
por
52,
2 por 5 = 10,
llevamos 1,
2 por 2 = 4 y 1 = 5,
2 por 1 = 2,
bajamos un 0 aquí
pues estamos multiplicando
por 50,
5 por 5 = 25,
llevamos 2,
5 por 2 = 10 y 2 = 12
llevamos 1,
5 por 1 = 5 y 1 = 6,
hacemos la suma, 0,
5 y 5 = 10,
llevamos 1,
2 y 2 = 4
y 1 = 5,
bajamos el 6,
el punto decimal dos lugares a la derecha,
así es que tiene que dejar 65,
lo cual es correcto,
1 entero 1/4 por 52,
1/4 de 52 es 13,
52 más 13 es igual a 65.
Así es que Luis debe dejar 65 dólares
enla mesa incluyendo la propina.